i ragazzi con questo video sono parigi
sono qui con al suri al toro nel chianti
marty col nickname di salvo e ti
chiamerò salvo perché invece la partita
mi chiamo salvo power salvo power in
questa mappa lui cade e io l'ho salvo o
mamma mia ha detto questo ragazzino di
salutare benissimo so che sei orgoglioso
di fare video con me allora vi spiego
stava per costare salato spiego la volpe
stranissima ci sono questi blocchi e tu
devi ai sono cinque salti c'è scritto
jobs remaining per arrivare dall'altra
parte punto che ha chiesto dal the sun
dà risalto prova a saltare
che figata quindi uno è un ottimo
aspetto è cristo politici possono
partire 12 è difficile io ho fatto 8
mappe per cui siano le mani e viso mai
per non vale ok diversa ogni volta
chiari ricotti series e risale sagacia è
per forza altrimenti buone aumenta la
difficoltà quindi hai solo cinque saggi
non è male sta cosa
ok ma questi livelli sono semplici per
adesso idee raisi già qua un casino io
parlerei dallo stelo possibile
ecco possiamo partire dall altra ci si
può invece sì ma tu sei perfetto fai un
salto di scala cit preservare e
difficilissimo è immagine satellitare e
tornare all'atomo mammamia 9 questo già
difficilissimo
forse semi se saltiamo il team i picchi
in aria riuscì roviamo proviamo a varese
un adventure mondo a sé sì si può si può
far caja e la tecnica la scusa perché la
miss cappella the grid immagina
l'editing di questo video was evola
questa clip jumpcut di noi tra quaranta
minuti esalteremo nero web sul web cam
che tentiamo una la tastiera sul muro è
esattamente quello che fa 100 tv due
prove come si fa a fare sta ma poi
dobbiamo farne più di volontà bensì wi
fi ma non possiamo questo è davvero è
veramente difficilissimo voi a dover
scegliere mappe semplici malapena questa
non ho mai trovato un banco così non
durò tre fatta dai dai
ho fatto a un capitolo dove si fa ho
capito in si fa è vero non è così
semplice però però
me lo sento perché è più semplice di
saltare come un mondo spastico però
certo quello che stavamo facendo da un
ora ok va bene
prendi la tua destra ce la faccio una
sento no sono fatto salvo batte mai
arrivati vaud è più o meno dove capire
come fare una volta che puoi fare il
primo cosa facciamo sono ho capito ho
capito capi rapido ci sono sospetta 1
easy peasy easy due bikers sport non ho
mai alle morti ok ma voglio fare slalom
faccio sulla route e non lo slalom è
stato un po cattivello gay sono due
risoluzione non serve a niente nella vi
sono tutte le servono parlavano fatto la
partita tra parte arrivo anch'io ceri
votivi elevata il bravissimo a cerci poi
caricato di passaggio una risaia
mammamia meno male meno paletta guarda e
cerca un ter deferirà destra è vero
luigi 46 livello 4 che ciò cosa
arancione sono rosse lo tocchi secondo
memorià come vediamo no a notti ha tolto
tutti i salti però in compenso non ci
sarà main in bocca e quindi va assaltato
aspettativa segui con noi al islah in
cosa facciano un sogno mi saltano mi
salta più note saltato però lo
completato abbiamo diciamo che partisse
bravas analisi però usando arriva sino
livello 4 che è tre volte più facile del
livello 3 no perché se lo vedevi saltare
poi sull'azzurro che tiri da salti
quello quello sicuramente noi dico il
livello che abbiamo appena fatto molto
bene infatti è mai sempre m m dai salti
easy ma non può arrivare alla fine è un
po campo città dal psi questo è
impossibile o possibile a pompare random
non fare a caso le voci così labile sta
roba naja
non ho capito come cose che lo trigger
ecco l'abbiamo quasi fatta
cavolo ma ce l'ho fatta
sei fortissimo secondo che siamo eccomi
perfetto livello non si sa come si fanno
le cose ma si fa al mio interesse giusto
così ora questo ci siamo detti salti a
meno che tu non debba fare un salto così
è facile fatta non so come ma mi hanno
mi ha resettato i salti non lo so vabbè
adesso siamo ricordi prima però abbiamo
capito che si fa quindi ok filati via ti
lo faccio subito c1 è visto come lo
faccio subito salvata quasi tutti ma
l'ultimo a salvo perché ci sono ce l'ho
fatta ce l'ho fatta
milano 10 marzo ora mamma mia
lotito mignolo che in allora pietà e può
dare un lucchetto azzurra ad un aspetto
della salt aiuti colpisco tra 21 via
bravissimo ora ci hanno funzionato non
si sveglia mamma mia e me tattica e
muove niente salta è ma quel blocco
azzurro sono e serve a qualcosa io ce
l'ho fatta io voglio blocco azzurro va
bene sappiamo pure lui ci interessa chi
serve al 12 quando di saltare dentro
no è no oddio questa roba qua ma questo
è difficilissimo dei ragazzi per questo
video tutto per tutto quindi speriamo
che vi sia piaciuto aspetti emotivi
insieme a misura di 2 3 1 2 ora 45 ei
eccolo hai capito allora sono i salti
sincronizzati che attivo tutto è ok
pronto dl capita mentre tu non ti sei
vai via ok 321 via o bravo questo volevo
ora dorata sempre mano nella ii poi non
mi ricordo cosa c'è dopo però è molto
321 via o di una mia se sto sudando ti
ricordi nera l'altro più o meno 3 2 1
via
si salva se lo aspetta emo siamo morti
tre due uno via proprio di no
ma cosa sta facendo mamma mia
incredibile amico mio ti senti pronto
prontissimo 321 via non ci credo non è
vero salto
va bene il suicidio il contento va bene
allora aspetta prima capire come
funziona qui salti o no è no vedi che ci
sono toniolo sono fortissimo salvo
affanculo poi mi sono iscritto al
partito
no basta questo ti prego basta quello
che fanno i livelli di un secondo
eccolo cimone vero dai ti voglio
uccidere ad avere fatto apposta
il legale questa con una mamma mia
ok ok abbiamo ammirato sia su questa è
la pelle ultimo è la morte e questo lo
sa già che la morte questo è l'ultimo
livello il livello 15 signori siamo nati
fino qua 321 via da 21 via 321 vi
aspetta che ci muoviamo ripresentarmi 31
via tra 21 via
ok aspetta aspetta 32 o 64 se no si a321
via via perché non è comparso vi ho
saltato lo giuro tanti credono
ti chiedo chi dar fuoco a casa ma ti
crea va bene 321 via via
ok a 7 a 4 a 4
ok 321 via salta salta non soltanto te
lo giuro non per ora che ci stiamo
mangiando un salto può essere variati ma
22 è ancora lì dove deve stare lì
l'hanno l'aspetto 64 li amiamo ci
fermiamo ci sembra che farlo anche senza
momentum qui facciamo per potervi un
singolo dei mini non aspetta un momento
ma vada che dava l'a321 via trento via
ok beh 4 3 2 1 via 321 via como poi lui
la decide lui
la deciderò chi si aspetta che c'è
scritto pure farò le leggi aspetti un
libro che non sa leggere leggo io faccio
il libro ho scritto c'è scritto chi
legge stupido f si apra pietro lasciamo
qua lasciamo pattern pietro e non è
quello che mi aspetto vero cosa che mi
aspetto
ma no ma ti pare va bene però ci stava
dopo il nostro caso non ci stai di renzi
quindi ragazzi
lasciatemi piace nova pera che ha
veramente sono contentissimo grazie
salvo alerno voi come sempre ci troviamo
nella zona zen e ci vediamo in un
prossimo video ringrazio salvo iscritti
al canale un prossimo video su qualsiasi
cosa modern warfare 2
quello lì ragazzi
[Musica]